but just in general like how I heard
like it's really visceral and how is
that in the gameplay you know overall
it's probably one of the best looking
games and uh on the Xbox series X oh
yeah it's definitely one of the most
visually stunning looking games ever you
know you don't even just Graphics it's
like the small features they do like
when I hit there's like
assassination uh animations where like
if you're using like melee weapons like
let's say brass knuckles or something if
you if you stun them and do the correct
prompts you literally punch a hole
through their head
it's some of the craziest Gore I've ever
seen like I noticed when like I I
knocked down a zombie I cut his leg off
so he couldn't chase me anymore and then
he's sitting there like he's crawling to
me and then I cut one of his arms off